Senegal and I didn't attain it so I'm
not gonna set any more goal right it's
like no you set a goal that was
inappropriate I want to own a house okay
well let's think about how we're gonna
get there rise and shine it's aunt
spresso time what's up believe nation
its Evan I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine so let's start
your day off right together grab your
coffee and sip on today's message set
goals properly over to you Jordan B
Peterson also if you want to know what
Jordan and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below if you're gonna
speak effectively you have to know way
more than you're talking about
[Music]
you don't tell your kid here's an
impossible thing why don't you go out
and fail you say here's something worth
going after here's a step you could take
that would push you beyond where you are
but that you also have a reasonably high
probability of succeeding at right they
called that within a time frame it's in
some timeframe that's the other thing
you have to parameterize it with regards
to time frame that's right and that puts
you in the zone of proximal development
and that's that's a concept that was
generated by a guy named Vygotsky he was
a Russian developmental psychologist and
the smart one it's where the idea of the
zone comes from to be in the zone and
when you're in the zone you're expanding
your skills in a manner that's
intrinsically rewarding because you're
succeeding and so you want to set if
you're good to yourself you think okay I
need to set a goal but I need to set a
goal that someone is stupid and useless
as me could probably attain if they put
some effort into it and then you go then
you've got it perfectly because it's not
so high that it's grandiose or
impossible that you fail necessarily and
then justify your bitterness it's like
well I couldn't do it well because that
happens to Pete how much all the time
yeah it's like this all the time you
know it's like it's yes exactly well I
set a goal and I didn't attain it so I'm
not gonna set any more goal right it's
like no you set a goal that was
inappropriate for the time frame that's
right you didn't calibrate it properly
and and you're playing a trick on
yourself because you want it to fail so
that you could justify not having to try
that's why being a victim mmm yeah which
isn't in helpful you're still gonna be a
victim like there's no way out of that
man so yeah you know because life is
this life is a challenge that in some
sense can't be surmounted so there's no
way out of your problem but there are
certainly proper ways of dealing with it
yeah now I've got a really special bonus
clip for you that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for a
question of the day I want to know after
watching this video what new goal would
you like to set for yourself write it
down and leave it in the comments below
so I like to think of okay this is the
ideal lifestyle that I want and I talked
about idea for your money right what's
that have your money targets and what's
how much would that cost you not right
not how much you roughly maybe no let's
calculate that yeah and what I realize
is after all these years talked to so
many people whatever the idea that they
have they say I want to be able to
travel I want to be able to have to
drive this particular car or have this
particular house or this kind of
lifestyle when they actually break it
down yeah doesn't cost them as much
right after thing data oh the ice most
wanted me all in dollars I need ten
million dollars only there's it rowing
it random numbers yeah because they said
a number that's totally unrealistic
versus Oh actually no I could accomplish
all I want to accomplish with maybe
three hundred thousand dollars a year
yeah well that's a very different goal
than thirty million dollars a year right
you don't know you can't know how you're
gonna conduct the war before the war
starts you can have an idea but you
can't know fully just like if you were
to say hey my goal is to X in my life
you don't know how you're gonna be able
to do that yeah because you talk about
cuz you're gonna just gonna make it
adaptations things are gonna come up
things are gonna change the battlefield
changes your life changes things pop up
made things happen so I think that that
idea that you're gonna know how you're
gonna execute something is is
far-fetched I think you well actually I
should use the word idea you should have
an idea of how you're gonna do it yeah
you just have an idea like okay well
this is what I need to get done this is
what I want to achieve in my life yeah I
want to make I want to do this mmm-hmm
what's the simple one I want to own a
house that's a simple one that's a good
place to start yeah I want to own a
house okay
well let's think about how we're gonna
get there you know that's that's this
thing about how we're gonna get there
you have to build your credit you have
to how do you build your credit you have
to you have to borrow money some people
something they go to buy a house they've
never borrowed money before you can't
borrow money if you've never borrowed
money you can't borrow money for a house
if you've never borrowed money for a car
or a or a or some smaller object before
so you got to establish your credit then
you gotta have two years worth of income
then you gotta have a big fat
downpayment sittin ready so there's
things you got to do this thing good now
now that might change across along the
way the idea is that you got to move
towards that goal that's what was so
nice about hearing
Vietnamese commander's intent get close
split them up mmm boom you go make that
happen
hey guess what you want to buy a house
one day save money have good credit yeah
okay well you got to make money how you
can make money you might make it driving
uber you might make it
delivering pizza you might make cuz you
got your real job with that support in
your family but then you need a little
extra to throw in there well that's why
you end up driving uber you end up with
whatever it is you're gonna do you make
your some money on the side that you can
start stashing away yeah you got to fill
your life with a bunch of goals so you
don't get gem cuz I guess you have small
goals that lead to the big goal right so
for instance you want to be financially
secure and stable what are you gonna do
you're gonna save some of your money
okay that's one thing you're gonna buy a
house that's another thing you're gonna
pay off your car and you're not gonna
buy expensive dumb cars you're gonna buy
cheap cars until you have the money to
buy him with cash you're gonna make all
these will think you're gonna work extra
you're gonna you know you're gonna do
these things so you're right you have
you have your broad goal yes you have
your long-term goal yes and then you got
your short-term goals that lead and are
strategically aligned with that
long-term goal raise your standard it's
not one drop of my self-worth depends on
your acceptance of me if you want more
Jordan Peterson check out the top fifty
rules video that I did on him I think
you'll enjoy it the link is right there
next to me continue to believe and I'll
see you there if you're failing
repeatedly it's possible that there's
something wrong with the way that you're
conceptualizing the world